air travel is a major source of co2 and
other greenhouse gas emissions and China
doesn't show any signs to cut theirs the
country is already the world leader in
co2 production with just under 10
million tons of carbon dioxide a year
that's almost a third of all global
man-made co2 each year while world
leaders were debating climate change in
New York China unveiled the second
biggest airport in the world soon to
handle more than 70 million passengers
per year Chinese President Xi Jinping
cut the ribbon for the 60 billion dollar
project completed in just four years
time to be one of the largest airports
in the world dodging is ready to serve
45 million passengers per year initially
and is set to expand to capacity over 70
million it has four runways and 268
gates a new high-speed train connection
allows for a fast trip from there to the
Chinese capital as clearly shows that
for China economic expansion seems to
come before climate protection how much
sense does it make if we all reduce ours
well let's bring an Alexander fight suit
on he's with the e3g an independent
climate change think-tank here in Berlin
like Sunday Germany produces just 2% of
global co2 just introduced stricter
climate regulation China opens a new
mega airport how much sense does all
this well-intentioned climate action of
countries like Germany make if were
leading co2 emitters like like China
obviously don't care it's a good
question I guess there are two sides of
the story
8 China has a massive economic growth
fishing we're talking about a city with
more than 20 billion inhabitants million
inhabitants 1.4 billion inhabitants in
China rising middle class of course
there's a high demand we have a growth
rate in aviation of 6 percent per year
so it's in a way a rational project for
China on the other hand what we can see
in China is a lot of camera action
it's the largest manufacturer of solar
PV for example and the wind and solar
already quite cheap
so I guess they should have China is
while they're moving in some sectors
that really not moving in Addis and
that's the big challenge on Germany I
would August it offset though you know
that they're producing lots of solar
panels does it somehow offset their co2
emissions no it doesn't it doesn't I
mean and they're they're meeting the
targets but the targets they have for
2020 2030 are obviously to live for the
Paris climate agreement so I guess for
the next year's the big challenge is to
cooperate with China there is a big role
for the EU to play as a role model
showing how this works cooperating with
China on being more ambitious on both
sides and that's what we're hearing from
Chinese officials we want to see a lot
of ambition from the EU then we will
move as well well being a role model is
an interesting discussion going on
because many people say yes we must be
of Germany's and in particular must be a
role model but others say the strict
climate regulation will hurt the economy
how much of a role model will we be as
Germans if our car industry goes down
because we introduce climate layer
legislation I actually see the other way
around
I think Germany has to move on camera
action to remain competitive I guess the
big question for the German car industry
do we still sell cars in 10 or 15 years
and they will probably more be eCourse
than the course we are having right now
so for Germany I think it's quite
irrational from a competitiveness point
of view to move right now how will
German British or Mexican car owners
ever be convinced to scrap their diesels
to do their bit while others do nothing
well they need the matter of the street
I'm talking about definitely - dude I
think that the issue you're having with
nice it's not that Germany is doing its
homework I mean you have this climate
package but it's by far not enough so
this perception that Germany's moving
while others are moving not it's just
not true okay where are those moving
company comparable economies are moving
in a comparable way or maybe taking
bigger steps as France doing more
France in the UK I mean from an emission
point of view I mean there is this big
roll of coal of course where Germany and
China at two of the major emitters
China's number one Germany's number four
so this plays a big role in co2
emissions and this is where those
countries play a bigger role and then
there's of course this big question
around shared
responsibilities China arguing well we
have to catch up we have economic growth
we need to make our people happy well
you're already rich and that's the big
conversation we're having an
international level yeah well that's
that's a very valid point but how much
climate protection is economically
viable so there are recent numbers by
the OECD basically showing that the net
effect on GDP of ambitious camera action
is positive in most g20 countries I
think it's 18 out of 20 so it is
rational the issue is less about the
economic case I would say that some
sectors are heavily affected of course
the coal sector will disappear where
others will benefit we have major crop
sectors like energy efficiency renewable
energy mobility so these are the
opportunities sectors I guess the issue
is how do we manage the kind of for
example coal how do we manage the
transition of the core industry do you
think that China in the very near term
and everybody says it's high time that
we reduce co2 emissions in a very near
term will put climate protection before
growth what makes me optimistic is that
it's not only a moral question for China
there's also a lot of national interests
they do already have very high economic
costs because of climate change and
major issues around air pollution around
the certification for example so they
have good reasons to move and next year
is actually quite important there will
be a major EU China summit they're both
hopefully try to work together to work
towards more ambitious climate policies
Alexandre Hudson thank you very much for
this analysis